welcome to this video valve Vereen
Wolverine yeah I recently lost one game
against the skywriter I have the nagging
feeling something went wrong against him
some bank oh yeah I remember so we're
going to play a rule or pass um okay
let's go for the brayer variation okay
play with d3 yeah I don't know c65 it's
both possible yeah he just it seems that
he's playing the the same stuff all the
time this kind of this kind of
information which is not not bad i mean
not saying not saying that but you just
play he's playing it so quickly that it
seems that he's going for that in no
matter what i do basically okay so g64
Bishop g7 let's not a bad place for the
night 95 sometimes sometimes possible
yeah so 95 or is this stupid probably is
so let's just complete this fianchetto
orvieto as someone pointed out I'm
always pronouncing it in a wrong way yep
I do ok let's see Queen age for was the
idea that
head yeah why not looks feasible gee 395
but this this is this is good like right
now wait wait wait wait it is good but
it's nothing super great now you can
serve cover cover his weakness here 22
might be might be good but I need to
combine the same and now fatigue Queen
d2 yeah attacking on c3 of course he
plays everything absolutely instantly at
the critical most critical position of
the whole game this is an instable okay
Bishop is six on d5 is also just
d phi f makes lots of sense actually
takes Queen c3 looks rather strong
okay some firsts check on and probably
not taking taking first this is better
okay and give this chick or this check
or take before yeah not easy Queen
defaults also move and not a bad one if
he goes on this on the 7th ranked at the
check so he had to do this maybe mr.
plated so feelin not sure if he had to
do it but he played it yeah I'm taking
on before it's not not so great can
shake and then click on d5 yeah because
it's a now it's not a self-penned but
almost chair
Jeff queena three maybe I can then drop
back try try for that have seven is
difficult difficult to protect we should
we should be six can take queen bee
seven funny enough time morning and this
year's Rookie of seven and half
difficult the site is difficult yeah I
mean it's not playing any good move
whatever but it's a it's difficult to to
not lose on time if he's playing
instantly all the time this is some
still nothing really I think
you have the same yeah of course
i def seven I don't know yeah I've got
20 seconds check
okay this check he just played for this
is check here on one aged one check
check yeah I it's a double check yeah
this is also willing as I'm sure it's
difficult I mean we didn't do anything
just played very very instant moves and
I mean I just have to be precise here
like it back it's just clearly better
but I have to a must be precise but I
wasn't that simply wasn't okay this is
this is probably okay rucca hate me I
don't know let's just look at this I
really cannot believe in that at all so
d5 looks correct takes Queen takes we
should be true so how do i need to plow
do i need to play this is probably right
here ie4 was winning evil I don't
understand why but if or seems to win
what is the point and then queen a1 and
Bishop before okay these wires suspected
that I'm clearly betters all his pieces
are unprotected and this night is not in
the game yeah I mean okay he's got this
thing on Evan going but it's this is not
working and this is this is hanging and
so on cannot work it just should be good
for black and it is good but have to
play you for him yeah not this move yeah
that's the problem I mean he blitzed it
all our one-minute 430 you want to move
or something but you have to find those
kind of moves that really kill now Queen
a1 and be sure
before is the big threat okay the the
best line according to two stock fish is
something like that and black is just
just completely winning him check
something something like that I mean did
the pawns I did quite funny I got two
bishops yeah I mean I wasn't so far i
know the clock right here i mean i was
still ok i have spent two minutes for 26
move this is not bad even here i was
playing quickly with d5 this is already
cost me some time but it is strong so
not not really a big issue here here and
while here if or was the killer check
the bad problem is that this on the
other hand isn't that great Bishop takes
Queen B 2 and here look at seven would
have one already didn't see it right
this one ok takes King edge 7 yeah their
community 6 is still still ok yeah
whatever s is just too slow I mean it is
difficult i mean this guy is displaying
every move instantly and as long as it's
not blundering something totally and I
have to find those kind of strong moves
this is difficult to play against here
this this stuff like this this is e form
with that's not so easy I mean certainly
doable but I couldn't so probably
probably deserved win him I mean I
probably never losing this with an
increment but we don't play with that ok
well thanks for watching